let's talk about ERGS
first of all
what is an ERG
an Employee Resource Group is an employee form
group of volunteers
focus on creating more diverse and inclusive culture
within their company
typically these groups comprise of
individuals that share a common interest
identity or affiliation
ergs might contain members of a specific ethnicity
gender sexual orientation
or religion
don't identify as a member of that group
but don't worry
many groups welcome people who want to be allies
to those in the workplace
erergies offer employees the
space to share their stories
support one another's personal
and professional developments
and connect on their shared identities and interests
creating spaces
where employees feel accepted and valued
can improve employee satisfaction
and help them succeed in their roles